[Music]
it's the moment the crowds always turn
out for a chance for the whole family to
stand together but not this year the
queen deciding that only working royals
will be on the balcony at the end of
trooping the colour so no harry and
megan and no prince andrew i think that
the queen's decision on this occasion
for the platinum jubilee focuses again
the public's mind not only on her and
her service but on all the members of
the family who are dedicated to support
her
as head of state
some will of course see this as a snub
which is why it won't have been an easy
decision for the queen to make but in
lots of ways it does again show her
trademark common sense shutting down all
the speculation and trying to bring the
focus back onto what the weekend is
really all about
but another surprise was coming as other
royals were marking archie's third
birthday on social media the sussexes
announced they will be coming for the
jubilee weekend and with the children
but keeping us guessing about which
events they'll be attending
and with a month to go it is the events
the palace really want us to talk about
this for example is what the stage will
look like for the big saturday night
concert
and they were desperate to show off this
the gold state coach that's going to be
the centerpiece of sunday's pageant and
hasn't been seen out in london for 20
years
it's an iconic coach in itself i mean
you know from my point of view it's the
most magnificent in the world um
and
it's it's also i mean it's also a
touchstone for us it's it's a because it
was there it was there on coronation day
it's still not clear when exactly we'll
see the queen but adjustments are being
made for example she won't have to use
these stairs if she does go to some
pools for friday's service
a service of thanksgiving for a woman
who for seven decades has done
everything that's been expected of her
this time doing this jubilee on her
terms
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace